aujourd'hui je vous racontais l'histoire
des caméras cachées donc nous sommes en
1964 et vous avez vu pourquoi l'histoire
des caméras cachées parce qu on a fêté
les 30 ans de surprise surprise encore
ce week end sur france 2 nous sommes en
64 le pack de la télé c'est pierre
bellemare pierre bellemare qu'on ait eu
la chance de côtoyer avec qui est de
travailler avec lui avec valérie bénaïm
à la radio qui était exceptionnel il y
avait son acolyte jacques rouland ils
créent ensemble sur la deuxième chaîne
de la rtf la caméra invisible c'est la
toute première émission de caméra cachée
de l'histoire est ici vous allez voir
ils vont faire tourner en bourrique une
pauvre employé d'auto-école en
transformant son lieu de travail en
pressing ça c'est l'une des premières
caméras quand il regarde on regarde la
jeune fille que nous voyait arriver sur
notre écran c'est la frontière de
l'auto-école le patron de monsieur aux
lunettes de soleil et voilà lui dit il
vous allez commencer par me faire une
course n'est pas très loin d'ici
qui va vous prendre environ une demi
heure c'est pour nous laisser le temps
de transformer totalement pendant son
absence
auto écoles en fonction
après les voir comme notre décorateur a
bien fait les choses
c'est pas possible comment
[Musique]
oui ma femme
à boyardville et alors ça ça et ça c'est
une des premières caméras levier c'est
énorme quand même l'idée et le gant le
gars qui étaient vraiment là qui faisait
les caméras cachées il est plus drôle
c'était jacques legras voilà tout le
monde s'est inspiré lui
si vous ne le connaissait pas et lui
c'est un petit peu le la fesse de
l'époque
c'est un petit peu voilà regardez comme
jean yves lafesse comme voilà comme on
va dire voilà je suis pas aujourd'hui
exactement mais bon voilà il ya israël
merci moi aussi je peux citer des gens
regardez mon parti a payé cela donnait
un renseignement ont la cote c'est de 2
francs
chaput notre poste 2 2 francs le
renseignement avec
[Applaudissements]
pour le renseignement
et maintenant
moi personnellement
oui messieurs la junte est quand même
alors pendant des années c'est jacques
legras voilà qu'ils aient toutes les
caméras cachées à la télévision et
ensuite en 92
c'est là qu'il ya eu une révolution dans
les caméras cachées et la révolution
c'est patrick sébastien patrick
sébastien qui nous propose son grand
bluff et en fait son principe c'est est
à dire en fait la caméra n'est pas caché
puisque la caméra je vais aller tourner
sur des émissions déjà existantes et je
vais piéger les émissions ça a été un
énorme carton plus de 17 millions de
téléspectateurs 74 % de part de marché
regardez ce jour là il avait piégé jean
pierre foucault sur sacrée soirée
et regardez jean pierre voilà c'est
notre jean pierre colin michal à
françoise michel michel pichon françoise
eric à ma tante alice
projet sophie marion l'époque ça fait 3
janvier au mali vous étiez comme un
poisson points pour y être champion je
suis un fantôme gros cons ok d'accord
quoi je sais j'ai gentiment comment sa
génération commence maintenant vous
connaissez bien sébastien goulet s'est
très bien vous être aviez vous
connaissez très bien c'est parce que
très bien bonjour jean pierre foucault
[Musique]
ça c'était très très forte
rodez contre mathieu 17 millions de
téléspectateurs 74 % de parts de marché
pour un divertissement c'est le record
absolu c'est notre patrick sébastien qui
là ça c'est complètement fou m'acheter
absolument fan de cette émission c'est
un peu cette émission qui va donner
envie de faire de la télé moi j'adorais
j'étais comme un fou et donc après
l'arrivée du grand bloc de patrick
sébastien vous le savez en télé quand ça
se passe c'est que dès qu'un truc qui
marche
les autres se disent mais il faut qu'on
fasse la même chose où il faut pour
remettre les caméras cachées voilà à la
mode où c'est donc en 93
c'est france 2 qui décide de faire
surprise sur prise est de relancer
donc les caméras cachées importé du
québec grâce à marcel béliveau qui fait
un carton
donc au québec et ça cartonne ils
déployer les grands moyens
regardez on le voit avec cette caméra
cachée concernant michel drucker notre
pote michel qu'on embrasse regarder
tu as eu des problèmes météo n'ont pas
bousculé rien dit c-series ya deux ans
était paraît il va détruire mon bâtiment
détruit tout le champ est alors donc
maintenant ils sont partis de rechercher
aller il chercher puis gaffe quand même
là j'aime bien les jeux
[Applaudissements]
janot qui sont fermées lundi comme thème
il veut décoller [ __ ] mais qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait arrêtez arrêtez les
moines raison il ya une merde oui mais
il y a un problème il ya des chasseurs
complètement bourré on va commander sont
pas faits dans l'hélicoptère qui sont
tiré un coup de fusil et il ya un
forcené qui est dans l'hélico il ya un
chasseur qu'à tirer sur une pâle n'a pas
les casser en deux et ils ont tiré sur
les icônes heureux à part la pâle
[Applaudissements]
moyen des sous alors il faut savoir que
ces caméras cachées pas si on pourrait
encore les faire maintenant parce que
c'était des moyens de fou avec des
budgets de fou mine de rien benjamin
quand on voit ça c'est vrai que ça s'est
passé à madagascar maintenance
non mais c'est aussi le cas chez celle
là elle a dû coûter à l'époque je sais
pas peut-être cent mille euros tout
comme ça ça me déchire considérable
l'hélicoptère les caméras il ya des
baffles gigantesque ans c'est assez
aujourd'hui ce sera très compliqué
honnêtement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce
serait impossible de faire ça at il pas
possible alors moi je suis dit quand on
voit des émissions mine de rien ce vrai
ça coûte un million d'euros 1 million 2
ou 1 million de colons repart aussi
voilà voilà maintenant un million de the
box avec moi j'ai envie de voir des
émissions comme ça à gros budget voilà
mais c'est ça c'est ça coûterait pas
plus d'un million de je pense benjamin
donc à plein de téléspectateurs mais si
vous faites des caméras cachées que
aussi forte que celle là c'est
d'hélicoptères dans ses lacets cent
mille euros pièce tout ça fait d'aller
un peu compliqué de plus le plateau est
plus d'un vide d'un célèbre donc on sait
que c'est compliqué match de l'ol sait
combien il avait des stars énorme
belmont dessau de long tout le monde est
exactement l'heure à la fin on leur à la
fin ils riaient mais on leur faisait
signer évidemment une autorisation de
diffusion
et comme certains parfois avait été
passée à l'âge de montrer très négatif
méprisant à que personnelles parfois
racistes y en a qui refusait de longs
pendants des lauréats refusé qu'on
diffuse la sienne péter dans un
ascenseur et ses nerfs mais il a refusé
qu'on a diffusé parce qu'il était
extrêmement de l'agréable
évidemment les attachés de presse
derrière voulait à l'époque c'était pas
comme aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est tous comme on est à
l'antenne vous tout le monde google com
vous êtes l époque on avait tous des
tâches se déprécier dorment
voilà c'est beaucoup elle a refusé des
années 90 va nous faire une fin abrupte
révélations dans un instant comme il
sait bien le faire mais devant une
instance yoan fanise rails de jean yves
lafesse et de toute l'histoire des
caméras cachées on reviendra exactement
deux minutes je continue à vous raconter
l'histoire des caméras cachées je sais
que j'adorais ça on a du très très lourd
on a eu une révélation de base à
wasquehal stade du monde série que
j'aime
ils nous faisaient des révélations
pendant la pub question des jumelles j
non je racontais que parfois on dit
surtout surprise surprise c'est que il
ya des scénarios qui aller très très
loin et les gens réalisent et mal moi
j'ai pigé ma mère on en croit que ce
docteur en parachute adventist au saut
et le parachute b ne pas s'ouvrir et
assez mal vécu là c'est pourquoi en
direct on vous raconte l'histoire des
caméras cachées vous aimez c'est baba
raconté hier je vous ai raconté
l'histoire des télé crochets et là je
continue à vous raconter l'histoire des
caméras cachées donc en 93 c'est vrai
que france 2 comme ils ont vu le succès
du grand bluff sur tf1 et on y tient on
va essayer de lancer aussi une émission
de caméra cachée ils ont lancé surprise
surprise
c'est un concept qui était au canada qui
faisait un carton et ça a cartonné sur
france 2 pendant des années et des
années et en 95 il ya un nouveau type
c'est pas des caméras cachées mais c'est
plus des prend qu on va dire comme
aujourd'hui on dirait des procédés voilà
c'est les pièges et on a découvert un
journaliste vraiment pas comme les
autres il dit venir de troyes dans
l'aube
c'est bien sûr raphaël mezrahi il
réalise des interviews décalées et fait
en sorte de faire péter un câble aux
célébrités
et bien sûr on pouvait pas passer à côté
de ce moment culte avec le père de
benjamin castaldi
oui tu vas nous dira si tu en as parlé
après si tu en as pas bien sûr regarde
jean pierre castaldi bonjour vous êtes
grand costaud vous êtes encore bien pour
votre âge vous faites du cinéma du
théâtre et personnellement j'ai fait
votre connaissance dans l'académie des 9
j'ai un bout de temps touré jamais vous
n'aurez même si vous prenez pour un
acteur un gars pas suffisamment fait
sujet on voit suffisamment ou les autres
cet été j'étais sur six chaînes en même
temps pour parler parce que ce coup vous
allez en vacances lequel elle tenait
d'ailleurs répéter une pièce de théâtre
qui s'appelle les enfants de coeur et
vous allez la démarrer dans très peu de
temps dans dix jours
qui est-ce qui et quelle a été votre
motivation ce qui concerne le choix du
de cette pièce de théâtre donc l'hiver
dernier quand
l'hiver dernier j'ai repris j'ai joué
l'alternance a les bonnes questions soit
sûr que moi je regarde et lui il est
devant moi il décolle du scotch parce
qu'il fait tu fais quoi là la faute il
prépare sa caméra pour filmer on chez
les pauvres
concentre-toi genté papelard regarde tes
notes de merde effet pas chez les autres
merde
le père de benjamin castaldi cent des
caméras quatre histoires exceptionnelles
jean-pierre cattani benjamin est ce qui
te l'avais parler après on a parlé parce
qu'en fait ce que je vous dis vraiment
franchement ils ont passé assad incident
c'est que mon père quand il s'énerve ça
monte mais il n'a cherché vraiment il a
été très très loin iran ils m'appellent
il dit aujourd'hui j'ai failli tuer
quelqu'un il ya un gars qui m'avait
interview mais j'ai vu c'est jamais vu
un mec aussi nul que ça et non seulement
il est nul mais il m'a provoqué et
rencontres et effectivement je pense que
50 - ou dix ans - je pense que je pense
que mizrahi travers sept salons sur le
cul parce que non être extrêmement
d'airbus mon père oui son métier c'est
hyper important le théâtre et donc qu'il
est là pour vendre sa pièce il a estimé
c'est est ce que je fais est
épouvantable et c'est là que je pense
qu'il aurait rompu lui il a accepté
qu'on a diffuse il a accepté qu'on a
diffusé alors je vais même te dire je
vais même te dire un truc c'est que
cette caméra cachée a été diffusé aux
césar il sait grâce cette caméra cachée
qu'il a pu obtenir le rôle dans dans
astérix de sa route mais un peu sa
carrière bravo on a des infos à vous
donner on vous raconte l'histoire des
caméras cachées
il ya également quelqu'un qui nous dit
ces gens que jean paul belmondo jean
paul notre ami notre frère va qu'on aime
le plus grand qu'il il regarde
l'émission pour info il s'est fait piégé
par une caméra cachée sacré soir à la
sortie du film itinéraire d'un enfant
gâté
il n'a jamais refusé que la vidéo soit
diffusé et il n'a été jamais été piégé
par surprise surprise jean-pierre un
jean paul belmondo voilà jean paul qu'on
embrasse très très fort et j'embrasse
jeff aussi kate avec les jets qui est
formidable et qui s'occupe très bien de
notre jean paul heureusement que tu es
là mon def
on t'aime fort les chéris donc en 95 on
découvre raphaël mezrahi et il ya un
autre sale gosse sans doute le pire de
tous qui se balade dans la rue me et qui
lui aussi va faire un truc c'est pas
vraiment des caméras cachées
c'est bien sûr jean yves lafesse lui
aussi pour nous la vie dans la catégorie
caméra cachée quand je vous raconte les
histoires et les grandes
des caméras cachées oui c'était un sens
de la régie mais je vais vous dire un
truc sur son sens de la répartie aussi
parce que c'est un grand travailleur
regard des gens il a fait pour faire
plaisir aux abonnés de canal+ se faire
hara kiri du set
bonjour vous pouvez obtenir son second
coup il est gentil merci je vais écrire
mon la scène
excusez moi vous avez l'heure s'il vous
plaît
la journée de pêche a été bonne voilà
une vraie dans un filet excusez moi on
est passé le bouffeur de tubes pourquoi
ne vous faire de plus
puis merci monsieur monsieur une badoit
une bière comme d'habitude à je crois je
me suis assis charme à la barre
c'est génial la thèse que l'égérie de la
fête qui était vraiment qui faisait
beaucoup de choses à l'impro mais
également qu'ils travaillaient quelques
petits trucs avant c'est un bosseur un
jour il a fait citer tiens si je vois ça
ils se mettent ainsi en situation et il
avait une répartie il a toujours une
répartie incroyable gens il a fait ça
alors et ces années là sont vraiment
l'avènement de conneries dans la rue on
va passer bien sûr à deux autres gars
qui ont fait des trucs exceptionnel
c'est pascal sellem et laurent baffie en
plus qui sont très potes dans la vie
pascal sellem on se rappelle un moment
il est aussi visée des caméras cachées
aussi pour julien courbet dans sans
aucun doute que j'ai adoré mode et puis
pascal dans la rue il était extrêmement
drôle regarder parce qu'à celles
charlie or regrette pas de renier vous
n'êtes pas bien et pas l'heure s'il vous
plaît j'ai me dit c'est pas possible et
médias c'est mademoiselle au dépanneur
s'il vous plaît monsieur
c'est pas vrai première avancée est vrai
vous c'est vrai qu'il faisait ça je suis
sûr qu'on ferait ça aujourd'hui les gens
auraient très très peur a même demandé
l'heure dans la rue ça s'était plutôt ya
plus personne qui demande leur parce
qu'on a tous leurs sur les portables que
ça avance était logique de demander leur
dans la rue et plein de gens qui vous
demandez vous avez l'heure s'il vous
plaît c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ça
arrive plus du tout alors il ya pascal
sellem qui à son grand pote laurent
baffie hilare arrivé aussi de piéger des
gens tous les deux mais baffie tout seul
ça vole l'ours au milieu des années 90
et réaliser des caméras cachées pour
tirer ardisson
regardez là il prend la place d'un
buraliste et il est odieux mais odieux
comme on les aime c'est laurent baffie
regarde moi j'ai le goût rouge moi mais
ça me brûle un peu quand je fais pipi ça
vous dirait c'est pour qui l'essentiel
oui au nom que des filtres et des light
temps qui passe chérie hd qui place on
ya une dame qui écoutent ce que je dis
pas ça parce que j'écoute quand vous
téléphonez moi vous êtes inconscient
je connais pas dans ma femme pour
l'instant c'est odieux de 400 france
voilà monsieur plaisir ici notre service
volée cassez-vous maintenant libérer la
place pour les antillais pour la boule
elle atteindra 2,3 50 ans je me dérange
pas pour de françois cron laurent baffie
exceptionnel monnaie mais c'est vrai que
est il était il ya plein de gens il
paraît que l'euro il m'a dit plus d'une
fois et ça a failli mal se terminer pour
lui on l oublie alors après ce que vous
rappelez de dan bolender dan bolender
inutile dans l'émission de laurent
ruquier notamment eric on a tout essayé
il est il il était très bon franchement
il pouvait tout faire avec un sacré
aplomb et on le voit ici à la sortie de
la remise des césar en 2001 et pour lui
tout le monde a joué dans le fabuleux
destin d'amélie poulain
ça c'est très très très drôle on regarde
et il est et il est très très bon
d'annebault l'aude cependant d'avoir
joué dans ce film
quel film amélie poulain oui je trouve
que c'était bien là on lavelli % sur le
jeu de félicitations ces genres vous
êtes vous êtes content d'avoir joué dans
ce film amélie poulain
ah oui avoue je re vous êtes content
d'avoir joué dans amélie poulain oui je
suis assez content dans le rôle du
percolateur mais quand même une justice
en félicitations merci a été admirable
dans le film amélie poulain a raison je
ne sais pas moi alors le fait attention
à ce que vous faites pour nom oui alors
d'amélie poulain j'ai cherché surtout à
tirer partie de mon côté féminin comme
voit que cette perruque à peu près quand
bon vous quel rôle vous faisait d'andes
ans amélie poulain je jouais la mairie -
dominique farrugia expédie sur braz
dominique j'espère qu'il va bien en mode
homme et c'est vrai qu'il était très bon
dan bolender il était dans on n'est pas
couché à l'époque c'est vrai qu'il ya on
l'a perdu de vue mais il est extrêmement
nourris à la fin des années 90 début des
années 2000 le label
te pourrir lance le meilleur interpro g
de tous les temps c'est quoi ils ont
même vendu dans les avions voyons pas
souvent dans des avions vous avez aussi
des caméras cachées
ça passait partout dans le monde entier
c'est des petites caméras cachées samson
mais juste une petite musique que je
peux vous dire ils ont fait énormément
dessous ils soulignent les membres du ca
pour di pinto année aérienne regarder et
ça c'était un carton d'audience ont
regardé
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
ça
de très bas c'est très mal équipé alors
aux états unis il ya un mec qui
s'appelle andy grosse et lui fait peur à
tout le monde dans la rue lui bon
montrer voilà aussi à l'étranger les
caméras cachées c'est un carton et lui
c'était une star aux etats-unis ont
regardé ce qu'il faisait non mais chez
nous guillotin elle nous parle bien mais
qu'il est dans notre émission à
l'exceptionnelle sofico c'est merci
d'être avec nous on est en direct
elle nous parlait du joyau si un mec
greg iota là il est dans notre émission
merci à des pages avec une embellie de
la fionie tintin g t au on a au canada
on a aussi pour nous peut-être le plus
fort voilà je vous le dis pour moi c'est
peut-être françois damiens s'appelait
avance françois l'embrouillé et lui ça
est aussi une autre révolution dans les
caméras cachées il ya deux moments
cultes où ils se retrouvent dans une
boucherie corse
il est exceptionnel rappelez-vous ce
moment il se faisait passer pour un
tatoueur aussi le tatoueur faire le vus
par des fois j'en ai pleuré on à faire
des trucs qui me fait le plus rire
regardes et tu as fait sous sa gueule
pour les à papier pour bêtement vraiment
présenter automatiquement sous sa gueule
vous voulez donner
ça va peut-être à l'idée de l'abonné des
choix on peut très bien imaginer petite
bougie beaucoup peut-être ferruch coucou
petit père richissime toi même coup
petite peluche mais tu rigoles ou quoi
non mais tu me fais un vieil élan qui
ressemble à hénon année là qu'il ya deux
trois ans mais regarde tu m'as fait un
truc là ça ressemble à rien n'y a pas de
corps il ya une vieille que non mais
arrête toi si tu vas aimer mais t'es
malade dans ta tête
c'était magnifique ça le tatouage était
fou ça rigolait sa thématique et bien
sûr l'histoire des caméras cachées c'est
aussi la grande race sera bien entendu
la grande part à cinq qui va arriver
très prochainement elle est déjà prête à
la grande race racin qui fait
exceptionnel qui seront en direct bien
sûr quand on reviendra en plateau mais
en petit bonus
rappelez-vous n'a été coira mokhtar
qu'il était bloquée dans un ascenseur
il avait prêté les plombs mokhtar notre
agent de sécurité regardez ça ça fait
partie aussi des caméras cachées
[Musique]
il m'arrive est une galère une fois je
me suis retrouvé j'ai passé ma soirée
dans le truck la personne qui vous savez
combien ils sont venus me chercher
ils sont venus chez monsieur 18 heures
ils sont venus à trois heures
[Musique]
pour les îles basses dans toi tu vois
bien de tonique et frontier 2 200 pasqua
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon si elle
tous les chiffres comment sera agressée
et où le croyez
c'était l'égalité m'a dit qu'au bal
repère bien tenu et mokhtar que
j'embrasse port cros fini chez lui du
fan et leurs bijoux